CONVENING OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE WE WELCOME
YOU THIS IS OUR LAST REGULARLY
SCHEDULED HEARING OF YOUR BUT
DO BE AWARE WE ARE ANTICIPATING
A FEW HEARINGS BETWEEN NOW IN
THE NEXT FOUR AND A HALF WEEKS.
EITHER OFF THE FLOOR OR WILL
GET THEM PRE SCHEDULED THIS IS
GONNA BE OUR LAST REGULAR
SCHEDULED HEARING OF THE YEAR
AND WE ALSO HAVE AN INTERIM
HEARING WORKING WITH THE CHAIR
OF SENATE TRANSPORTATION IN THE
ASSEMBLY CHAIR OF
TRANSPORTATION ON ALL ISSUES OF
SCOOTERS. IN THE GREAT SITTING
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO WHICH WE
WILL BE SENDING A SAFETY THE
DATE OUT TO ALL MEMBERS HERE
MOMENTARILY FACING GERMAN WE
HAVE THREE BILLS ON THE DOCKET
TODAY A. B. TEN A. B. TEN
TWENTY SEVEN IN AB FOURTEEN
FORTY TWO WE'RE GONNA BE
CONVENING AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
MOMENT WE'RE GONNA WELCOME THE
GOOD IS A MEMBER OF FROM. SAN
FRANCISCO WERE GRATEFUL THIS
AND NUMBER TWO IS HEREBY TAKE A
MOMENTOUS THANK YOU TO SEND THE
VIRTUE. IT IS AN ABSOLUTE
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH YOU SIR
AND MEAN IT WE LOVE WORKING
WITH VIA. CELL NUMBER THE FLOOR
IS YOURS ON A. B. TEN. THANK
YOU LET ME ALSO JUST START BY
THANKING YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
YOUR DEEP ENGAGE WITH US ON.
MANY BILLS THIS YEAR AND I
APPRECIATE THAT WORK. AB AND-
IN THE MIST OF OUR STATE'S
WORST HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY THIS BILL
WOULD EXPAND. ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST EFFECTIVE
HOUSING FINANCING TOOLS ARE
STATES AFFORDABLE HOUSING TAX
CREDIT. INCREASING THE TAX
CREDIT BY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH WOULD IN TURN LEVERAGE.
ANOTHER BILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL TAX CREDITS LOCAL AND
PRIVATE SECTOR INVESTMENT.
WHILE I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
INCLUDED A FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE. ON LIKE THIS
BILL THE INCREASES ONE TIME AND
FUTURE INCREASES WOULD BE
SUBJECTED TO AND
APPROPRIATIONS. AS YOU WILL
HEAR FROM OUR WITNESSES
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
LINE UP FUNDING SOURCES YEARS
IN ADVANCE. AND INVESTORS NEED
CERTAINTY. FROM TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN TO TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN OUR STATE LOST ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS IN. THIS TAX
RATES INVESTOR EQUITY DUE TO
FEDERAL TAX LAW CHANGES. AND
HAVING A STATE TAX CREDIT THAT
MAY OR MAY NOT BE FUNDED IN ANY
GIVEN YEAR WILL MAKE IT VERY
DIFFICULT TO ATTRACT INVESTORS
WITH. LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO A
WITNESSES THANK YOU SO MUCH
THEM OVER TO OUR WITNESSES YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES WE WELCOME YOU
WHO WOULD LIKE TO THEY KICKED
OFF. PERSONALIZE NAY WHEN
ORGANIZATION HEY I WELCOME BACK.
MEMBERS I JULIE SNYDER
REPRESENTING HOUSING CALIFORNIA
A CO SPONSOR OF AB TEN AS YOU
WELL KNOW ACCORDING TO THE
STATE HOUSING DEPARTMENT
CALIFORNIA IS CURRENTLY SHORT
ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
HOMES THAT ARE AFFORDABLE THE
CALIFORNIANS EARNING LESS THAN
HALF OF THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME.
AND THE SHORTFALLS NOT GONNA
DISAPPEAR OVERNIGHT BUT
CALIFORNIA CAN MAKE VERY STEADY
PROGRESS TOWARDS THE DAY THESE
FOLKS ARE NO LONGER HOMELESS OR
PAYING TOO MUCH FOR RENT IT IS
GOING TO TAKE BOLD STRATEGIES
THAT HAVE PINPOINT TARGETING TO
HELP THOSE WITH THE LEAST UP
FIRST AND AB TEN FITS THIS BILL
IT INCREASES APPROVING TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM THAT WE KNOW
GENERATES RESULTS. THE PROGRAM
NEEDS NO RAMP UP IT WILL SERVE
YOUR CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE LEAST
LIKELY TO BE SERVED BY THE
PRIVATE MARKET FOR THIS REASON
WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO BE A CO
SPONSOR AND REQUEST DRIVE OUT
THANK YOU. I THINK BEING HERE
GOOD MORNING MORNING CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS RIGHT AWAY WITH A
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
OUR FOLKS ARE THE DEVELOPERS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND OTHER
PEOPLE INVOLVED IN PUTTING
TOGETHER DEVELOPMENT DEALS I
JUST WANT TO EXPAND A BIT ON
WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
MENTIONED WE'RE REALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE INCLUSION
IN AB ONE A ONE OF THE ONE TIME
EXPANSION OF THE STATE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX. PROGRAM
THAT'S GOING TO DO IT. AGAIN
SIGNIFICANT. THE AMOUNT OF
PRODUCTION AND DEVELOPERS ARE
ABLE TO DEAL ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
WE NEED TO HAVE THIS BE AN
ONGOING SOURCE TO THE GAME PLAN
FOR THE FUTURE. AND PLAN ON.
INCREASING THAT PIPELINE ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS AND FOR THAT WE
REALLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
TO SEE YOU WERE IN A WELCOME
ANYONE WHO'S IN SUPPORT THE
BILL. FIRST CLASS ORGANIZATION
GOOD MORNING. MORNING JAKE OF
REGULAR THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANKS TO GET. A GOOD MORNING.
ON COMEY DOES ON BEHALF OF THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA THEIR CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. JOBS ARE THANK YOU.
HEY. ONE NOT MUCH. GO AT KIANA
VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA IN
VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH IS SOMETHING. GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING CHECK
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PLAY JOHNSON
HIM AFTER IT SHOULD IF YOU
ANIMATE PROTOCOL SPONSORED THIS
BILL AND PROUD TO SUPPORT. FOR
BEST MISS MINE I SEE SIR ANYONE
ELSE WHO'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE IN
SUPPORT. HEARING SEE NINE
NUMBER TO WELCOME ANYONE WHO
MAY BE OPPOSED PLEASE PORT.
HEARING SEEN OPPOSITION WOULD
LIKE TO TURN OVER TO THE
COMMITTEE TO BE TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
I WILL START WITH THE VICE
CHAIR ANY QUESTIONS COMES VICE
CHAIR. HERE LOOKING UP AT THE
AMOUNT OF TAX CREDITS SEVEN.
PROVIDED OVER THE LAST TEN OR
FIFTEEN YEARS TO ADD I DON'T
SEE IN THE STATUS STAFF REPORT
LIKE A LIKE A CHARGE OF HOW.
THE STATE HAS BEEN DOING TO
DATE AND I'M. SORRY THAT I
DIDN'T HOLD UP SOONERS DEAR
GOOD GETTING BACK FROM BREAK I.
DIDN'T GET TO TIME I'M JUST
WEARING DOES DOES HOUSING NOW
I'M GETTING TO SOMEONE'S
GETTING TO AN ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
WEBSITE DOES HOUSING CALIFORNIA
PROVIDE AT THAT DATA. IT WILL
ROUGHLY WERE AT ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR UNDER
THE CURRENT TAX CREDIT PROGRAM
SO OF THE LAST TEN TO FIFTEEN
PROBABLY ABOUT A BILLION. SO
WE'RE DOING KIND OF A FLAT
HUNDRED MILLION A YEAR. EIGHT
IT'S BEEN ABOUT SEVENTY EIGHTY
MILLION FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS A
HUNDRED MILLION THIS YEAR I
THINK A COUPLE THINGS OF NOTE
FOR THAT IS IT'S WOEFULLY BELOW
WHAT THE STATE USED TO SPEND ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO. BEFORE
THE GREAT RECESSION WE SPENT
ABOUT ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR MORE THAN WE'RE
CURRENTLY SPENDING AND SO THE
TAX RATE AS I'M AS I MENTIONED
IS AGAIN BETWEEN SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OF THE PAST.
DECADE ALSO PROBABLY UNDER
SUBSCRIBES TO THE NEED IS
CLOSER TO ABOUT A HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR AS FAR
AS THE NUMBER OF PROJECTS THAT
ARE LOOKING TO GET FUNDED
AROUND THE STATE BLESSING I'LL
JUST MENTION AS I. MENTIONED
BEFORE IS EVERY DOLLAR THAT WE
SPEND AT THE STATE LEVEL
LEVERAGES TO FEDERAL TAX
DOLLARS ON TAX CREDITS AND THEN
AND EVEN MORE FEDERAL DOLLARS A
SORT OF LOCAL DOLLARS AND
PRIVATE SECTOR INVESTMENT SO
AGAINONE PRIVATE SECTOR ONE
STATE DOLLAR OF INVESTMENT.
CHUMS ANOTHER THREE FOUR FIVE
OTHER DOLLARS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING INVESTMENT AND THAT'S
WHY IT IS APPRECIATED.
WONDERFUL BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGH THE PROCESS. YEAH MAYBE
I COULD. TAKE IT DOWN TO A
DIFFERENT LEVEL. HOW MANY HOW
MANY DEVELOPERS HAVE REQUESTED
THE CREDIT. AND HOW MUCH HAS
BEEN GRANTED AND IT IS THE
AMOUNT OF REQUESTS HIGHER OR
LOWER THAN THE AMOUNT THAT'S
AVAILABLE SO AS I AS I SAID
EARLIER IT HAS BEEN MASSIVELY
OVERSUBSCRIBED SO I WOULD SAY
AT LEAST I HEARD UNDER
SUBSCRIBE SO NOTE SO FOUR FIVE
TIMES AS MUCH ANTICIPATED
DEMAND IS FOUR FIVE TIMES WHAT
WE HAVE AND THAT'S WHY THIS
BILL IS MOVING FORWARD. WHEN IT
VERIFY THAT FOR THE RECORD
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU I
THINK THIS VICE YOUR THINK THE
LESS THERE IS WE HAVE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TWENTY FOUR
PROJECTS BENEFITTED JUST FROM
THE STATE SIDE BUT HUNDRED TWO
MILLION IN THAT YEAR IS WELL
WITHIN THAT AS- THE GRUESOME
AND SAID AT LEVERAGES FEDERAL
DOLLARS TO COME IN AS WELL. SO
OR GO TO THE CHAIR OF
TRANSPORTATION. WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR HIS WORK ON AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. WE. OF JUST GOT THE
WORD ON THE NO FOLLOW THE
NOTICE OF FINANCING A BILL
REALLY FOR THE HOUSING BONDS
THAT WERE APPROVED BY THE
VOTERS. LAST YEAR THEY HAD
THREE TIMES. AS MANY
APPLICATIONS AS MONEY AVAILABLE
SO THERE'S LIKE THIS PENT UP
DEMAND RIGHT NOW FOR THESE
PROGRAMS AND ARE I ASSURE YOU.
EVERY DIME OF THE TAX CREDITS
WILL BE IS IT WILL BE JUST
FLOWING OUT VERY QUICKLY AS
SOON AS WE. MAKE IT AVAILABLE
TO HOUSING DEVELOPERS BECAUSE
THERE'S JUST YET AND UP. THE
MAN I KNOW FOR THE HOUSING
BONDS IT WILL CONTINUE TO BE.
AT UP DEMAND FOR SEVERAL YEARS
NOW. NO ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK RECEIVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. CURRENCY
NINE GREAT BILL SHE TO WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM BUT WE'D LIKE
TO GET OFF FOR CLOSING COMMENTS
ARE JUST A PROJECT THE
COMMITTEES CONSIDERATION OF
THIS ONE OF THINGS ARE BILL FOR
HIS ONGOING LEADERSHIP AND FOR
MAKING A POINT OF JUST HOW.
MUCH DEMAND THERE IS FOR THIS
WE NEED TO BUILD LE HOUSING AT
ALL LEVELS AFFORDABILITY AND AS
REBUILDING MARKET RATE HOUSING
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE ALSO HAVE MECHANISMS TO MOVE
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRODUCTION WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT SO MUCH OF MISTER CHAIR
WERE VERY GRATEFUL IT'S GOOD TO
SEE SIR. TO ACTION AS SOON AS
WE HAVE A QUORUM IS ALWAYS
COULD SEE LEASE AS WELL THANK
YOU MUCH OUR WITNESSES WHO ARE
HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'RE GONNA BE IT BRING IT
UP THE CHAIR WOMAN WATCH OUT
THAT. SHE'S BRINGING IN AB TEN
TWENTY SEVEN SECURE WOMAN BURKE.
WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM AT THIS
MOMENT BUT WE'RE GONNA TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO YOU WE WELCOME
ALWAYS CARLOS IN THIS ROUGH TO
THE COMMITTEE IS WELL PLEASE
MADAM CHAIR A FEEL LIKE AN
UNDERACHIEVER YOU OF LIKE
WATER. CANDY FOR EVERYONE. YEAH
I NEED TO GET IT TOGETHER I
THINK GUYS ON THAT MORE BILL
THIS IS BRING THE CAFFEINE NEXT
TIME SO WE'RE WE'RE GOOD WE'RE
GOOD. OKAY WELL I GOTTA FIGURE
SOMETHING OUT HEY THERE. OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
TEN TWENTY SEVEN WHICH MODIFIES
THE CALIFORNIA COMPETES TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM BY ALLOWING THE
STATE TO DIRECTLY INVEST IN
SOME CALIFORNIA'S BEST
PERFORMING COMPANIES AB TEN
TWENTY SEVEN WORKS WITH THE
EXISTING CAL COMPETES FRAMEWORK
BY ALLOWING A TAXPAYER TO OFFER
AN KRISTIN IT'S COMPANY AS PART
OF THE CREDIT APPLICATION
PROCESS THIS OPTION IS
COMPLETELY VOLUNTARY AND ME AT
THE ELECTION OF THE TAXPAYER BY
ALLOWING THE STATE TO CONSIDER
AN OWNERSHIP INTEREST AS ONE OF
THE FACTORS INEVALUATING AN
APPLICATION SMALLER COMPANIES
THAT ARE UNABLE TO MAKE THEM
STAND VESTMENTS. COMPLETE ORDER
COMPANIES OFFER A BETTER CHANCE
OF FINE FOR A ADDITIONALLY IN
THE STATE IS IN THE SUCCESS OF
COMPANIES WILL ALLOW US TO
RAISE THE CAPITAL NEEDED TO
MAKE ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT
ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT IS
CURRENTLY ALLOCATED BY GOBIZ IN
FACT IF THE TEST IMPLEMENTED
SUCCESSFULLY MEDICAL BILLS CAN
BECOME A SELFISH SELF FUNDED
PROGRAM AB TEN TWENTY SEVEN HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION THANK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ARE ABLE
THANK YOU SO MUCH MANAGER
PRECIADO YOU WERE AS WITH ACT
BETTER OPEN. IT UP TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE
I'M FOR. PLAN FROM THE MORLOCKS
TO THE SENATE FOR THE OTHER DAY
WAS GREAT TO BE TO SEE ALL THE
GRAND BABIES WHOSE COULD STOP.
MY GOODNESS. WELL BEHAVED
UNLIKE THE GRANDPA. HEY THERE
YOU GO. THOSE VERY COOL THOUGH.
YEAH IT WAS NICE TO FLY THEM IN
FROM WISCONSIN AND THAT'S COOL
I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO THE.
ARE THEY HOME NOW OR FLYING AS
WE SPEAK. MANY OBVIOUSLY
MILWAUKEE BUT WE TOOK THEM
AROUND SACRAMENTO WE DID THE
GREAT. WE DID THIS SACRAMENTO
TRAIN OUR UNIT FOR LUNCH ON
SUNDAY AND WE DID. WHAT TO THE
JELLY BELLY FACTORY YOU KNOW WE
DID ALL THESE. WITH GRAND KIDS
AND WE JUST HAD A GREAT TIME I
DID NOT EVEN KNOW THAT AND- I
HAVEN'T BEEN ON THE TRAIN I TRY
TO GET ON THE TRAIN IT
CHRISTMAS TIME BECAUSE THEY
HAVE LIKE A SPECIAL CHRISTMAS
TIME THING BUT YOU HAVE TO DO
IT REALLY EARLY. YEAH AND I'M
NOT THAT ORGANIZED. TRAIN
ROBBERY. ACTORS ON BOARD ALONE
SUNDAY. AND AT THE END THE
ROBBERS APOLOGIZE TO MY FOR YOU.
AND HE APPRECIATED THAT BECAUSE
HE WAS PRETTY SHOOK UP I BET.
THEY APOLOGIZE. A VERY EAGLE AS
AMERICANS MIKE QUESTIONING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'M JUST
THE THERE'S A AT A HISTORICAL
TERM CALLED GRUB STEAK AND A
LOT OF MERCHANTS WOULD. GIVE OF
MINING EQUIPMENT TROUBLES AND
ALL THE REST TO MINORS FOR A
GRUB STAKE IN IF THE MINOR DID
WELL THEN THE MERCHANT WOULD
OWN A PORTION OF THE MINOR THE
CLAIMANT AND SO THAT WAS JUST
LIKE IN THE ARTICLE IS A RISK
KIND OF A THING I AND I'M KIND
OF SITTING HERE GOING THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL REMINDS ME OF
ITS CREATIVE IT'S BUT I I'M- I
WERE READY TO GET. FROM OUR
BUSINESSES 4% HAVE FUN MONEY
YES INCOME TAX AND PROPERTY TAX
AND PAYROLL TAXES AND SO I'M
TRYING TO GET MY ARMS AROUND.
THIS CONTENT. THIS IS IN LIEU
OF THAT THIS THISIS SO THAT
THEY CAN GET THE CREDIT. THIS
IS AN ADDITIONAL CREDIT THAT
THEY WOULD BE APPLYING FOR AND
SO THIS IS WE DON'T THERE'S NO
POTENTIAL LOSS FOR THE STATE.
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT EXTENDING
CREDIT OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT
PARTNER EXACTLY SO THERE'S NO
ACTUAL RISK IN THIS CASE TO THE
STATE AND IT WOULD JUST GIVE
THEM AN ADDITIONAL. CREDIT
RIGHT BUT IT WILL GIVE THE
STATE THE RIGHT TO. AUDIT THE
BOOKS AND ONLY WELL ONLY AT THE
TIME WHEN. BUT LIKE WHEN WE
FIRST DECIDE WHAT THE ACTUAL
VALUE OF THIS THE COMPANY IS IN
THE STATE WOULD INTO AN
INDEPENDENT. AUDITOR WOULD
AUDIT THE COMPANY TO DECIDE
ACTUAL VALUE. AND THEN WHEN IT
CAME TIME TO SELL THERE WOULD
BE AN INDEPENDENT EVALUATION.
AND IF IT JUST DIDN'T WORK OUT
AND IT. NO LOSS TO US WE DIDN'T
GIVE THEM CREDIT WE DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING. WELL I'M I'M JUST
TRYING TO GET A DO WE HAVE ANY.
SIMILAR PROGRAMS AROUND THE
COUNTRY AT THE STATE. CALPERS.
TOPICS ARE THE RIVER CALPERS A
BY STOCK OF A COMPANY THAT'S
THAT'S DIFFERENT ANIMAL
ALTHOUGH THEY HAVE INVESTED IN
THE PAST AND SPECIFIC. AN
IMPRESSIVE PROJECT MICROPHONE
ON ANY GIVEN THE SENATORS IN
SEVERAL YES THE CARLSON DOWN
ASSEMBLY REVENUE AND TAXATION
COMMITTEE. CALPERS HAS IN THE
PAST INVESTED IN INDIVIDUAL
COMPANIES THEY DON'T ALWAYS DO
THAT SOMETIMES THEY GO THROUGH
A LARGER INSTITUTION THAT
INVEST IN INDIVIDUAL COMPANIES
THEY DON'T ALWAYS INVEST. JUST
IN STOCKS PUBLICLY. TRADED
COMPANIES YEAH IF IT WITH
BRIGHT THEY HAVE. OTHER OTHER
VENTURE CAPITAL THEY CAN INVEST
IN BUT THIS IS THIS IS WORK
COMPANIES COMING UP AND SAYING.
WE WANT TO CREDIT BUT WE'LL
GIVE YOU SOMETHING FOR THAT
CREDIT TO TRADE OFF. RIGHT AND
THEY'RE APPLYING ANYWAY SO IT'S
JUST SIR OTHER COMES SO THIS IS
JUST AN ADDITIONAL FACTOR THAT
THAT CAN BE CONSIDERED AND THIS
IS INITIAL VOLUNTARY FACTOR
THAT CAN BE CONSIDERED. SO
THEY'RE ALREADY COMING FOR THE
CREDIT THIS IS JUST AN
ADDITIONAL FACTOR THAT THING ON
I'M LOOKING AT IS A CPA KINDA
GOING HOW WHAT I WOULD WHAT I.
WHAT I CALL A IT JUST DEPENDS
AND IT ALSO DEPENDS ON THE SIZE
OF THE COMPANY FOR A LARGER
COMPANY IT'S EASIER TO PRIDE
PROVIDE MORE INCENTIVES FOR A
SMALLER COMPANY THEY HAVE LESS
INCENTIVES AND SO THIS IS
ACTUALLY A BENEFIT TO SMALL
BUSINESSES. THAT ARE APPLYING
FOR THE CREDIT IS ACTUALLY WHAT
IT'S DESIGNED TO BE. SEVEN ONE
BURKE I REALLY LIKE THE
CREATIVITY. I IN THANK CARL.
IT'S IN MY GREAT SO THAT THE
STATE THANK YOU AND BRING YOUR
BRING YOUR YOUR GIVE A DAUGHTER
RIGHT YES I KNOW YOUR DAUGHTER
ON THE TREE I WELL THANKS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS VICE CHAIR
MANAGER IF IT WORKS FOR YOU
WOULD LIKE TO BE A QUICK PAUSE
BUTTON IN A SOURCE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM WE HAVE HER TADO NIELSEN
IN THE HOUSE WHICH WERE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT WELCOME. IN
LET'S ESTABLISH FORMS THANK
CHESTER PLEASE. REQUIRE PRESENT
MORE LOCKED. PRESIDENT BELL
THEY'LL PRESENT HERTZBERG
RICARDO. HOW TO PRESENT NIELSEN
DOES THE PRESIDENT WIENER. THE
GENTLEMAN MISTER WINNER MISS
HERTZBERG ARE IN THE RUNNING
TODAY FOR THE AWARDS SO WE'LL
SEE HOW THAT'S GONNA WORK OUT.
I WOULD LIKE TO GO TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS
THAT YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE WITH.
CHAIRMAN BURKE OTHERWISE WE'LL
HAVE A CLOSE. HEARING SEEN NINE
MANAGER WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE I
JUST WANNA THINK COLINFOR I
MEAN WE ALWAYS WORK WITH COLIN
BUT CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
COLIN AND THE CONVERSATIONS WE
HAD OVER THE BREAK AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY. MOVING
THIS FORWARD AND TAKING HIS
COMMENTS INTO CONSIDERATION. I
APPRECIATE THAT COLIN IS AN ALL
STAR THING WITH YOUR TEAM. WE
LOVE WORK WITH YEAH IN VERY
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP. THANK YOU MA'AM
CHAIR. I DO HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR. WITH THE MOTION BY
CENTER TYLER THE MOTION IS. TO
PERFORATIONS MISSING CHESTER
CAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CHOIR
I REQUIRE ALL RIGHT MORE LONG.
HERTZBERG FURTADO. THE CAR ALL
RIGHT NIELSEN THOSE IN HIGH
WIENER. CURRENT ENJOYS A THREE
ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN AND HONEST FOLKS
COMPETING SO MUCH VENTURE.
THANK YOU. IS IN GERMAN WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO OPEN THE
ROLE ON ITEM NUMBER ONE ITEM
NUMBER ONE. I DO NUMBER ONE IS
AB TEN IS THERE A MOTION FROM
COMMITTEE ON ITEM ONE. WITH BY
SENATOR BATTLE THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS MISS LANCASTER
CAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WIRE
HI WHY I'M MORE LOCK. BELL
THERE ARE THIRD RICARDO RICARDO
I NIELSEN YES I WIENER. KERN
ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO VOTE WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THE ROLE OPEN PLACE
IN GERMAN WE'RE NOT GOING TO
BRING UP OUR FINAL BILL OF THE
DAY AND WE WILL TAKE A MOMENT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO SOMEONE
WOMAN RIVAS PLEASE IF YOU DON'T
MIND COME FORWARD TO SOMEONE.
THIS IN THE WOMAN AT BROUGHT
FOR THIS IDEA. BUT BY ANY OTHER
INDUSTRY GROUP BUT THAT THIS
WAS AN ISSUE THAT WAS IMPORTANT
TO HER WE WANTED KNOWLEDGE YOUR
HARD WORK ON THE SHARE OUR
VALUES TAX CREDIT ON YOU HAVE
BEEN PUT IN A LOT OF BLOOD
SWEAT AND TEARS INTO THIS ISSUE
WE JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU.
ARE AND WE ALSO WANT TO SEE A
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THIS BILL WE'RE
GONNA TRY IT OVER TO THE
SOMEONE TO BE ABLE TO PRESENT
IN THE WILL OPEN IT UP FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE SOME OF THE FLOOR IS
YOURS A GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND- FRIENDS
I'D ALSO LIKE TO START OFF BY
THANKING YOU AND- COMMITTEE.
FOR HELPING WITH THIS
LEGISLATION THE YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF WAS INVALUABLE IN HELPING
CRAFT THIS AND SO NOW I'M VERY
EXCITED TO BE HERE TO
PRESENTED. I WILL BE IN THE
COMMITTEE IS PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THAT REDUCE. REDUCE
THE ALLOCATION TO FIFTY MILLION
PER YEAR OVER FIVE YEARS. ALSO
THE TECHNICAL CLEANUP LANGUAGE.
OF AB FOURTEEN FORTY TWO
ESTABLISHES THE SHARE OUR
VALUES FILM TAX CREDIT. AND
WITH THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
WOULD ALLOCATE FIFTY MILLION
PER YEAR FOR FIVE YEARS. FOR
FILM PRODUCTION RELOCATION FROM
STATE SEEKING TO RESTRICT
WOMEN'S REPRODUCTION RIGHTS.
OPERATIONALLY THE LEGISLATION
MIMICS THE EXISTING FILM TAX
CREDIT THREE POINT NO THAT
MEANS THAT THE FILM COMMISSION
PROVIDES OVERSIGHT AND DEVELOPS
RULES AND GUIDELINES. CREDITS
WILL BE ISSUED ON A FIRST COME
FIRST SERVE BASIS AND AS AND
THIS IS ONLY OPEN TO APPLICANTS
WHO DID NOT RECEIVE RELOCATION
TAX CREDITS UNDER THE EXISTING
THREE POINT OH PROGRAM. SIMILAR
TO THE PROCESS ESTABLISHED IN
THE. THREE POINT OH FILM TAX
CREDIT WHICH REQUIRES AN
APPLICANT TO SUBMIT A NARRATIVE
STATEMENT IN ORDER TO RECEIVE A
RELOCATION CREDIT. AB FOURTEEN
FORTY TWO REQUIRES THAT THE
APPLICANT SUBMIT A NARRATIVE
STATEMENT DESCRIBING HOW THEY
SHARE CALIFORNIA'S VALUES.
GUARDS TO REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
SEVERAL OTHER STATES AND
COUNTRIES HAVE ACTIVELY
RECRUITED THE FILM INDUSTRY
FROM CALIFORNIA MAINLY THROUGH
EXTENSIVE TAX CREDIT PROGRAMS.
RECENTLY NEW MEXICO NEW YORK
ILLINOIS AND OTHERS HAVE SOUGHT
TO ENTICE INDUSTRIES FILMING
AND STATES. OF WITH STRICT
ABORTION LAWS TO RELOCATE THEIR
PRODUCTION TO THOSE STATES IN
CALIFORNIA THE FILM INDUSTRY IS
ONE OF OUR FLAGSHIP INDUSTRIES.
CALIFORNIA'S FILM TAX CREDIT
NOT ONLY GENERATES CORPORATE
INCOME TAX AND PERSONAL INCOME
TAX REVENUES BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY WE ARE NOT FORCING
THESE EMPLOYEES TO SEEK WORK IN
STATES THAT HAVE SHOWN THEY DO
NOT VALLEY WOMEN OR THE
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS. FOR TEXT
ON THE ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF THE
FILM INDUSTRY ACCORDING TO
RECENT STUDIES WITH A TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
INVESTMENT APPROVED PRODUCTIONS
WOULD GENERATE NEARLY ONE POINT
NINE BILLION OF DIRECT IN STATE
SPENDING. THIS MEANS SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION AND QUALIFIED
WAGES SIX HUNDRED MILLION AND
QUALIFIED VENDOR EXPENDITURES
AND THE HIRING OF MORE THAN SIX
THOUSAND CAST AND NINE THOUSAND
CREW MEMBERS. THE COMMISSION
STUDY HELPS QUANTIFY THE LABOR
AND ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF
FURTHER INVESTING IN THIS FILM
TAX CREDIT. WILD IS FIGURES ARE
IMPRESSIVE THERE ARE OTHER
FACTS AND FIGURES THAT ARE
EQUALLY NOTEWORTHY. ALABAMA
RECENTLY BANNED ABORTION FROM
THE TIME A WOMAN IS KNOWN TO BE
PREGNANT WITH NO EXCEPTIONS FOR
RAPE AND INCEST. GEORGIA BANNED
ABORTIONS AT SIX WEEKS THE
STATE CAN INVESTIGATE WOMEN'S
MISCARRIAGES AND DOCTORS COULD
BE SENTENCED TO UP TO TEN YEARS
IN PRISON. I SHOULD ALSO
MENTION THAT GEORGIA HAS THE
SECOND WORST MATERNAL MATURE
BUT MORTALITY RATES IN THE US
IT'S TEN TIMES HIGHER THAN
CALIFORNIA. UNFORTUNATELY I
COULD GO ON AND ON. THESE ARE
THE SAME STATES THAT HAVE
SYSTEMATICALLY LOWERED FILM
PRODUCTION FROM CALIFORNIA. AB
FOURTEEN FORTY TWO PROVIDES THE
FILM INDUSTRY AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SHOW THEY STAND WITH WOMEN AND
SHARE OUR VALUES WHILE BRINGING
CRITICAL JOBS BACK TO OUR STATE.
I'D LIKE TO THANK MY CO AUTHORS
INCLUDING CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS SENATOR
LEYVA AND ASSEMBLY WOMANLY
MULLIN. I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK
ON LABOR FOR STANDING WITH
WOMEN AND THEIR RIGHTS. AND
TODAY I'M FORTUNATE TO HAVE
ALEX SECULAR WITH LABOR'S LOCAL
SEVEN TWO FOUR. AND KAREN
HUMPHREY PUBLIC POLICY CHAIR
FOR THE NATIONAL WOMEN'S
POLITICAL CAUCUS OF CALIFORNIA
TO PROVIDE. BRIEF TESTIMONY
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
AN LIMóN PRECIADO DEAD WHO
WOULD LIKE TO GO TO KICKS OFF
STRAGGLER PLEASED TO FLOOR
SORCERY OF TWO MINUTES WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS ALEX ANNULAR I AM THE
BUSINESS MANAGER FOR LABOR'S
LOCAL SEVEN TWENTY FOUR. WHICH
IS AN AFFILIATE WHICH IS
AFFILIATED WITH THE LABORERS
INTERNATIONAL UNION OR NORTH
AMERICA. BETTER KNOWN TO ALL OF
YOU AS LIKE YOU IN A. LOCAL
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR REPRESENTS
OVER SIXTEEN HUNDRED MEMBERS
LABORS WHO WORK IN THE MOTION
PICTURE FILM AND TELEVISION
INDUSTRY. RETURNING FILM AND
TELEVISION PRODUCTION WORK TO
OUR GREAT STATE IS A TOP
PRIORITY FOR US AND THAT IS WHY
WE ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
SHARE OUR VALUES TAX CREDIT. WE
HAVE CONSPICUOUSLY BEEN STRONG
ADVOCATES FOR BOTH THE CREATION
EXTENSION OF THE CALIFORNIA
FILM. AND TELEVISION PRODUCTION
INCENTIVE IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND THIS
IS WHY WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
FOURTEEN FORTY TWO IN ITS
EFFORT TO ENCOURAGE AND
INCENTIVIZE ADDITIONAL FILM AND
TELEVISION PRODUCTION RETURNING
TO CALIFORNIA. THIS IS A TIME
OF GREAT CHANGE AND ALSO OF
GREAT OPPORTUNITY IN OUR
BUSINESS WE BELIEVE CALIFORNIA
IS IN POSITION TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THESE GREAT
OPPORTUNITIES. AB FOURTEEN
FORTY TWO WOULD CREATE
THOUSANDS OF HIGH QUALITY WELL
PAYING JOB OPPORTUNITIES AND
BENEFIT THE STATE'S OVERALL
ECONOMY IN THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
ON BEHALF OF OUR SIXTEEN
HUNDRED MEMBERS I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT WOMEN AND LEVERS THAT
WORK IN THE FILM INDUSTRY. AND
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY WOMAN THREE OF US FOR
SUPPORTING WOMEN AND LABOR AND
WORK IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.-THANK YOU SO MUCH
REPRESENTATION TO REGRET FOR
YOUR HERE MISS HUMPHREY WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HANGING WITH US
THIS MORNING. THANK YOU
RESOURCE OF TWO MINUTES. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AT. AM IS KAREN OFFRAMP PUBLIC
POLICY CHAIR OF NW PC
CALIFORNIA. A NATION WAS
POLITICAL CAUCUS AT THE STATE
AND NATIONAL LEVEL AND THROUGH
TEN LOCAL CAUCUSES IN
CALIFORNIA. HAS WORKED FOR MANY
YEARS TO RECRUIT TRAIN AND
ELECT PROGRESSIVE PRO CHOICE
WOMEN TO PUBLIC OFFICE. AND
FIGHT FOR EQUAL RIGHTS FOR
WOMEN. AND ISSUE WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY CONTINUES TO
DIVIDE THIS NATION. IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE THE U. S. SUPREME
COURT'S LANDMARK DECISION IN
ROE V. WADE AFFIRMED EVERY
WOMAN'S FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT. TO
CONTROL HER OWN REPRODUCTIVE
DECISIONS HIS FIRST ON AND THE
B. PC'S LIST OF BOTTOM LINE
ISSUES. TODAY WERE SAYING
AGGRESSIVE ATTACKS ON WOMEN'S
RIGHTS OF STATES LIKE GEORGIA
ALABAMA AND OTHERS. PASS BILLS
TO RESTRICT A WOMAN'S ACCESS TO
ABORTION AND OTHER
REPRODUCTIVE. HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. WITHOUT THE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT OF
REPRODUCTIVE CHOICE WOMEN'S
RIGHTS. HELLO I'M US. IS
UNDERPINS ALL THOSE RIGHTS.
AWAY AS LONG SHOT THAT THE CITY
WITH WOMEN AND WILL PROTECT
THEIR RIGHT TO MAKE CRITICAL
DECISIONS WITHOUT GOVERNMENT
INTERFERENCE. AS ELSEWHERE WE
NEED TO CHALLENGE INDUSTRY TO
STAY WITH WOMEN. BUT REFUSED TO
OPERATE IN STATE FOR THE- I'M
IS REPLACE. AND REAR GATE TO.
THE DISK IS A SMALL. RESTAURANT
THIS IS. A PROGRAM THROUGH
WHICH THIS CRITICAL WE CAN
STAND. SO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS AND TO THOSE WHO ARE
WORKING WITH HER ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS MUCH
ASSEMBLY WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR WORK. YOU BEING HERE TODAY
THAT GO TO SEE IF ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. FOR THE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT CAN YOU PLEASE COME
FOR. HEARING IN SEEN NINE WHEN
OUR- I'M FOR LOOKING FOR
OPPOSITION HEARING AND SEEING
NINE WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO TURN
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
RECEIVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE'LL START WITH THE
WE HAVE A MOTION A MOTION BY
CENTER TADO. LIKELY TO SEE
BROUGH QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
HEARING SEEN NONE AT. THIS
RIVAS WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE A
CLOSE HER ON THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND DISCUSSING THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION AB
FOURTEEN FORTY TWO PROVIDES
CALIFORNIAN OPPORTUNITY TO KEEP
FAMILIES TOGETHER WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING BACK
CRITICAL JOBS TO OUR STATE
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE CINNAMON
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
ON THIS THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH COMMITTEE AT WERE REALLY
GRATEFUL WE LOVE WORKING WITH
YOU WE LOVE ORGANISED MEMORY
AND YOU WANT TO THANK YOU SO
MUCH. BROWN EYED. EXPERTS AS
WELL FOR ALL OF HER WORK. ON
THIS. WITH THE MOTION ON THE
FLOOR MOTION IS BY CENTER
TANTO. THIRD TITLE BE
PRESENTING OUR AWARD HERE IN
JUST A MOMENT AS SOON AS WE'RE
DONE. AYE THE MOTION IS DO PASS
AS. AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ISN'T JUST WORKING PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. HI WHERE ARE MORE
LOCK. MORE LOCKED NOBEL THEY'LL
AYE HERTZBERG RICH REGARD
RICARDO LARA AYE NIELSEN. DOES
THE NOW WINNER. THIS YEAR TO
DATE HE AS SHAVER RIGHT THERE
HAD PAYING WATCH OUT SO GOOD
STUFF HATE WE HAVE SOME BILLS
ON CALL LET ME JUST TOUCH BASE
HERE WITH MISSING CHESTER WILL
OPEN IT UP I DO BELIEVE THE
VICE CHAIR IT IS GOOD TO GO.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU.
WE HEARD US FOR OUR. YEAH YEAH.
OUR AYE LAZY JIM IS WHAT WE
CALL OUR BIG ROUND UP WE'RE
GONNA BE ROUNDED UP EVERYONE
DOWN VOTE ON EACH WERE THREE
BILLS FROM THE START WITH ITEM
NUMBER ONE THIS IS A BE TEN THE
MOTION IS DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT
CODE IS FOUR ZERO MISS
LANCASTER. HERTZBERG I. FIVE
ZERO. WE ARE KEEPING ON CALL
FOR MR WIENER WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO
AB TEN TWENTY SEVEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS THE
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO
MISALIGNED CHESTER AL. ALL
RIGHT HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG AYE
WIENER. FIVE ZERO WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THAT BILL ON CALL AND
WE'LL WAIT FOR MR WIENER AND
EVERYONE ELSE HAS VOTED ON ITEM
NUMBER THREE WE'RE GONNA TURN
IT OVER TO MR TADO THE BILL TO
PRESENT THE AWARD AND THIS
AWARD IS EXTRA SPECIAL TODAY
BECAUSE INDIVIDUAL STILL. IS
NOT HERE. THAT IS CORRECT AND I
WANT TO GIVE CREDIT TO MY
COLLEAGUE HERE BECAUSE HE DID
EARNED THE AWARD FOR THE MOST
PART ALL YOU KNOW. MOSTLY EVERY
WEEK UP UNTIL SUMMER RECESS
THREE BUDS TO DATE BE THE HONOR
GOES TO SENATOR WITH A WIENER
FOR. HIM TODAY HE EARNS B. S.
IN A RICARDO LARA. AWARD WE GO
LAYS IN GENERAL AND
CONGRATULATIONS TO CENTER
WIENER ANY WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE AWARD ON HIS BEHALF HERE
TODAY. AIDS IS. A IT'S PRETTY
BAD HERE TODAY LASER JET OF A.
MMHM LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. THE
GOOD CENTER FROM SEARS IS GO WE
LITERALLY HAD TO GIVE THE AWARD
TO ANNE TO GIVE DO YOU BECAUSE
YOU WERE SO LATE TODAY SO IS
AMAZING. HEY THERE WE GO
THEY'RE GOOD SENATOR THOUGH
PRESENTED ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE
TO GO TO SAY ANY PARTING
COMMENTS MADAM SENATOR. HEY
THERE YOU GO. I LIKE IT I LIKE
IT RIGHT THANK YOU JIM LET'S
OPEN UP THE ROLE WE HAVE THREE
ITEMS ON THE DOCKET ITEM NUMBER
ONE THAT START WITH A. B. TEN
THE MOTION IS DO PASTOR
PREPARATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO MISS LANCHESTER.
WIENER OURS. AT THE SIX HERE
WE'RE GOING TO BE CLOSING DOWN
THE ROLE. IN THAT BILL IS THAT
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB TEN TWENTY SEVEN
THE MOTION IS. DO PASSER
APPROPRIATION. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS FIVE EIGHT ZERO. ISN'T JUST
WIENER. WE ARE ALL RIGHT. SIX
SIX SIX ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE. WE'RE
NOW ON OUR FINAL ITEM ITEM
NUMBER THREE BE FOURTEEN FORTY
TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FOR TWO MISSING
JUST. FIVE FIVE TWO THAT BILL
IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE
AS A GENTLEMAN THANK YOU ALL
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
ENTIRE GOVERNMENT FIGHT TEAM.
UP FOR ALL OF THEIR WORK MISS
LANE CHESTER AND CALLING AND
MARNIE. AND OF COURSE DO YOU
GENTLEMEN REALLY REALLY
GRATEFUL JOHNSON THANK YOU SO
MUCH. FOR AN AND TIME FOR ALL
OF THE WORK WE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO SCOTT RYAN FOR ALL
THEIR WORK THIS YEAR OF COURSE.
AND WE WILL BE HAVING HEARINGS
OFF AND ON FOR THE NEXT FOUR
WEEKS AS BILLS COME UP. AT
WHICH I KNOW EVERYONE'S REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT DELAYS IN GERMAN
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL THE
HARD WORK THIS YEAR THANK YOU
TO OUR SERGEANTS AS WELL WE ARE
TRULY APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU
DANIELLE FOR DOING ALL THE
TRACK AND MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE. ON COURSE WE ARE ADJOURNED
.
INCREASE CERTAINLY OTHER.
CHALLENGES IN EXPECTATIONS OF
ON THE PART OF THE UTILITY AS
WELL AS THIS THE GREAT ITSELF.
DO YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO MOVE.
POWER FOR AROUND TO CREATE
CERTAIN REDUNDANCIES THAT
PERHAPS THE UTILITY DOESN'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO OR WHAT
THEY HAVE THAT THAT OPTION TO
DO WE WOULD WORK IN
COORDINATION WITH THE UTILITY
TO MOVE THE POWER AROUND AND
UTILIZE OTHER TRANSMISSION
LINES WERE NECESSARY SO THAT
WOULD ALL BE IN COORDINATION.
WITH THE US AND UTILITIES. GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH